it is often asserted that the world has
made a great deal of progress since 1776
that we have had new thoughts and new
experiences which have given us a great
advance over the people of that day by
the way isn't that exactly what we've
been saying in this course and by the
way put in one sentence and that we made
therefore very well discard their
conclusions for something more modern
but that reasoning cannot be applied to
this great charter he means the
Declaration of Independence in other
words some things sure
like if there'd been airplanes in 1890
people probably would have gone to
California on a plane instead of a train
and so in some respects most respects a
plane is a better way although there is
the transportation security agency so
many things change Coolidge is admitting
but something about this charter he says
the dead horse of Independence stays the
same and that's an interesting point
isn't it because one could then admit if
he wished and and looked like you would
have to that sure enough many things of
great importance change but is
everything change